people find it
surprising to put it mildly
that
the immediate family of the
uk chancellor
is not paying uk tax on a large part of
their income and people
non-dom status is legal
but i think we should be clear that
non-dom status is used to
it's not used to pay more taxes it's
used to pay less tax than you otherwise
would and you've got to say that you are
permanently resident
not in the uk that is part of your your
your resident non-domicile that is the
that is the way it works so she's caught
between a rock and a hard place as far
as india is concerned because they won't
let her
have um say that her residency is here i
do well that is not my 15 years and well
i'm ver that's i'm that's very
interesting if that's the case i'm
rather surprised about that because
there are lots and lots of people kay
who are citizens of other countries
not uk citizens but who pay taxes here
you don't you don't have to be a non-dom
you don't have to be a non-dom it's not
you're not forced to be it you choose to
do it in fact you pay a little bit of
money up front or start quite a lot of
money actually up front yeah quite a lot
money up front to get to be non-dom
status and and it's to save you money
you know in your in your overall tax
bill look i i think there are quest
legitimate questions that need to be
asked of rishi sunak about this um in
addition we've also learned today that
uh a business that she was involved with
here in the uk received hundreds of
thousands of pounds as part of the
furlough scheme it subsequently went
under so that is costing british
taxpayers money i don't know look i just
don't know that i don't want to comment
on that necessarily because i don't know
the details of that you know
you know that money could be okay well
i've been legitimately claimed i don't
want to sort of but you can accept that
what the chancellor is doing is
completely above board
on behalf of him and indeed his wife
i think it's legal but is it right
that's the question your viewers will be
asking they're unfacing a massive cost
of living crisis uh rishi sunak is the
man who is charged with ensuring that
everyone pays their fair share of taxes
and people will be asking is rishi's
united's immediate family paying their
fair share of taxes when they're not
paying uk tax on such a substantial part
of their income a lot of my viewers this
morning are concerned about how to be
paying their energy bills um a half a
million children have been forced into
absolute poverty as a result of the
taxes and the cost of living increases
that we've seen over the last
few weeks or so
clean energy might be the way forward
when i put that to quasi quartering he
was saying that we won't see any impact
on our bills for three to four years
well i'm afraid with the government's
plan you won't see any impact for a
decade because look new i'm actually in
favor of you nuclear but that's at least
a decade away okay that the real flaw at
the heart of this so-called plan that
they're publishing today is they have
rejected the cheapest cleanest most
secure form of power which is on short
wind and they've done it not because of
the national interest but because some
tory backbenchers said up with this we
shall not put we're not willing to relax
the ban that was put in place by david
cameron in 2015 onshore wind and your
viewers are paying significantly more on
their energy bills or as a result of
this and they will carry on paying more
on their energy bills because of that
decision and it's not just onshore wind
it's solar it's energy efficiency
nuclear all very well they should be
getting on now with onshore wind solar
and crucially insulating homes which can
make a real difference to your viewers
now okay so the conservative co-chair
will say hold your horses because what
happened uh back when you were the
energy secretary is that you didn't
invest the money that needed to be
invested in our energy infrastructure
this is what he said
our reliance today on russian oil and
gas was a course set by labor
governments
they were the ones who neglected to
invest in new nuclear power you know ed
miliband remember him he spent 10 years
blocking it when we could now be relying
on it
i mean they'll make up any old cobblers
weren't they
i mean
i mean look
let's be honest look
what happened was in 2006 tony blair
opened the door again to nuclear it was
controversial i took it forward as
energy secretary i left a plan for 10
sites for new nuclear we've had 12 years
of the government not doing it but look
all of that's ancient history they
should be getting on now with new
nuclear but they should be getting on
now okay with onshore wind solar and
insulating homes that's what could make
a difference to your viewers but it's
your fault that we're relying more on
russian
absolutely that's absolutely that's
absolutely nonsense because i started
the drive to renewables to offshore wind
and all of those things
do you acknowledge though that you know
some people don't want to live next to
um wind turbines uh
i do acknowledge that but here's the
interesting thing
significant majorities across the
country support onshore wind and you're
more likely to support onshore wind if
you live near a wind turbine than if you
don't live near one i was at a wind farm
yesterday and the guy that was saying we
have really significant public support
here this is a lot of mythology this is
tory back benches who are worried about
a few people in their post bag and they
are holding our energy our country's
energy policy to ransom would you live
near a wind farm yes of course and i
have wind farms in my constituency
of course i of course and and you know i
think the context for it has changed
kate you know we know the energy and
security we face with the situation
russia ukraine we know what's happening
to people's bills i think you know it's
long past time to be making excuses and
to be having this kind of band we need
all forms of power at disposal and the
government's rejected that course your
party is tying itself in knots about the
transgender row at the moment um
should we ban um trans conversion
therapy
yes
why do we why can i not get straight
answers from a lot of your colleagues no
no no from a lot of your colleagues
because you you know you've answered it
very clearly but a lot of your
colleagues seem to be very cool
including the leader seem to be very
cautious when we talk about transgender
well i think there are strong views on
lots of sides here but i'll give you my
perspective on this i think that
trans people face incredible barriers
and stigma in our society i was talking
to a trans person the other day about
this
i think the way this debate has been
conducted these anatomical debates
i think it is really awful for so many
trans people in our country who are you
know you've got teenagers who are trans
who are self-harming you know you've got
them facing incred and i think the
british people actually are respectful
and tolerant and want equality and and i
think we must be able to do that for
trans people and i feel like i've seen
some of this movie before k which is in
the 1980s around the way gay people were
stigmatized
you know i think i i i think we've
really got to stand up for the rights of
trans people yes we've got to hear those
women who say that there's a case for
single sex basis i understand that but i
do think that we've got to empathize and
recognize the pain that so many people
so many trans people face and treat them
with the respect they deserve what about
transgender women taking part in women's
sport
i think that we need fairness
i think that is a decision
for the sporting bodies though what do
you think
well i think it's different in different
sports i was reading the document that
uk sport produced on this i mean you
know they were saying look snooker and
darts might be different from you know
swimming or other sports i think i think
now i understand that yeah but my
question is should transgender women
have a blanket ban okay i don't think
you should have a blanket ban i think
it's i think it's for the sporting
bodies and i'm afraid this is the case
where you know the prime minister sort
of he blundered in yesterday and said
well you know suddenly he comes up with
a view well look you know i understand
that for example in the cycling case i
understand the strong feelings there
were there um and i think the sporting
bodies eventually got to the right
decision but i do think this is swimming
well you see that's the thing i don't
think it's for me to say i'm interested
in you yeah yeah yeah yeah
i think i think the principle here is
that we need fairness in sport right we
do need fairness and what this what this
uk sport document says is look inclusion
is important principle but so too is
fairness and i think that is a decision
for sporting bodies they they are the
people responsible for the rules here
and and i think they can enforce and and
come up with those right rules and so
you know going back to your original
question about the trans institute in
general they're i think we're showing
there are tricky issues here but i think
i come back to this point which is
how would you be feeling as a trans
person after what the debate the kind of
debates that have been had in the last
few weeks i think you'd be feeling awful
but how would you be feeling as a woman
swimmer who has been practicing their
entire life and you've not got any
chance at all against a transgender
woman in the same sport
that's why there needs to be fairness
and you know i understand that people
will feel that and there does need to be
fairness and the sporting bodies need to
take that seriously but i trust that
sporting bodies can take this seriously
without the politicians as i say
blundering in um partygate i ask every
um
cabinet secretary about partygate i they
all stonewall me they all say we have to
wait for the final reports we've already
had 20 fines so my question is actually
what your leader has said you know did
the prime minister preside over multiple
law rule breaking in dining street the
answer is yes but that was then we've
moved on
well
i don't think the public have moved on i
think there's a bit of a westminster
public thing here i think the public are
still pretty angry about it because i
think the public think this has been an
absolutely traumatic time we did the
right thing the vast majority of us did
the right thing and and there was one
rule for boris johnson another rule for
everyone else so i don't i don't i don't
buy that at all and obviously we're
gonna have to wait to see what happens
in relation to boris johnson but it's
clear there was a culture of rule
breaking in downing street presided over
by boris johnson uh let's end where we
started um what would your words of
advice be for richie sunak this morning
because you've been the eye of a storm a
few times
i think
explanation
explanation and then thinking to
yourself not just what is legal but what
is right he is the uk chancellor asking
people to pay more in taxes is it right
that his immediate family is sheltering
from uk taxes i think many of your
viewers will think it isn't right and i
think rishi sunak and his family should
reflect on that and is his wife a fair
target
i don't like i don't like that word i
don't think we should be thinking about
spouses as in that way i think i think
there's a very high bar for spouses
being part of political debate but i
think
the case in of of tax and the chancellor
and rishi sunax
immediate family is a legitimate
question okay my team always say to me
he's so relaxed now he's not leader
anymore what's all that about what's
happened to him he discovered a
personality
maybe other people have discovered that
i have a personality oh maybe you're
allowed to come out
before it's always great to see you
thanks for coming in